let me introduce myself i'm browsed my
real name is austin been working so hard
been recording these songs every night
and i'm [ __ ] exhausted ain't been
sleeping i'm still fighting demons and
nothing is helping to clear up my
conscience when i think about not living
up to my full potential i just start to
get nauseous need a psychiatrist wait
let me write this [ __ ] hold on just let
it ride don't try to fight this [ __ ] hit
record turn to annihilus don't know
defeat like podiatrists you know it's
gang like a tribalist hold on
don't get ahead of myself
[ __ ] that tell the engineer to punch me
in it just keep punching me until i
punch out their license you've been had
to drive with no license the heart is
the fire boy arson is double and triple
entendres i'm in my own world with the
juice like it's jamba mentality mom but
a boy been a problem and i'm so focused
you can read it in my persona see it in
my persona stepping and designing a
depth of photo designer if you forgot
then let me remind you i am no amateur
snapped like a camera whenever i switch
the flow is diverse it's not even close
i just feel like a ghost cause they
sound like a version of me at my worst
gift and a curse i'm stuck with it when
this [ __ ] get too much to bear for y'all
well that's when i go in like the
covenant code and i'm running it flow
got a ton of them straight gunning them
down not one of them found no cap in my
rap no cap with the gown i'm in my own
lane you can't [ __ ] with my sound i just
let them be bill just to break it all
down [ __ ] get cynical i can't stand the
praise i'm in love with the ridicule i
don't touch pen i ain't even touch
pinnacle i murder beats in two minute
intervals like wowzers grip might drown
her mic check one two turn me up louder
go harder than anyone out here until
[ __ ] click like internet browser lil
browse call me internet browser propane
through my whole name gotta search for
it they just wanna talk [ __ ] on the
internet won't admit it to themselves
that they just never wanna work for
that's fine i'm barely trying only two
years and then i'm on the climb give me
two or more i sell out the troubadour i
probably pack it full of rappers through
a door i'm off the top with no capping
like two fedoras kill the verses and
forget to do the carves talking facts
like a [ __ ] historian heard your new
[ __ ] it was whack it was boring it's
tough while i'm rapping you'll ruin
euphoria my [ __ ] is od like ruin
euphoria they cannot [ __ ] with the bull
like guitarists record every day until
my voice get horoscope on the
competition i've been navigating this
through intuition i don't know say they
don't buy when i turn on the flow and
they still wonder how far i could go
[Music]